Good morning everyone.
Today we are going to do some
algorithms, back to algorithms,
and we are going to use a lot
of the, well,
some of the simpler mathematics
that we developed last class
like the master theorem for
solving recurrences.
We are going to use this a lot.
Because we are going to talk
about recursive algorithms
today.
And so we will find their
running time using the master
theorem.
This is just the same as it was
last time, I hope,
unless I made a mistake.
A couple of reminders.
You should all go to recitation
on Friday.
That is required.
If you want to,
you can go to homework lab on
Sunday.
That may be a good excuse for
you to actually work on your
problem set a few hours early.
Well, actually,
it's due on Wednesday so you
have lots of time.
And there is no class on
Monday.
It is the holiday known as
Student Holiday,
so don't come.
Today we are going to cover
something called Divide and
Conquer.
Also known as divide and rule
or divide et impera for those of
you who know Latin,
which is a tried and tested way
of conquering a land by dividing
it into sections of some kind.
It could be different political
factions, different whatever.
And then somehow making them no
longer like each other.
Like starting a family feud is
always a good method.
You should remember this on
your quiz.
I'm kidding.
And if you can separate this
big power structure into little
power structures such that you
dominate each little power
structure then you can conquer
all of them individually,
as long as you make sure they
don't get back together.
That is divide and conquer as
practiced, say,
by the British.
But today we are going to do
divide and conquer as practiced
in Cormen, Leiserson,
Rivest and Stein or every other
algorithm textbook.
This is a very basic and very
powerful algorithm design
technique.
So, this is our first real
algorithm design experience.
We are still sort of mostly in
the analysis mode,
but we are going to do some
actual design.
We're going to cover maybe only
three or four major design
techniques.
This is one of them,
so it is really important.
And it will lead to all sorts
of recurrences,
so we will get to use
everything from last class and
see why it is useful.
As you might expect,
the first step in
divide-and-conquer is divide and
the second step is conquer.
But you may not have guessed
that there are three steps.
And I am leaving some blank
space here, so you should,
too.
Divide-and-conquer is an
algorithmic technique.
You are given some big problem
you want to solve,
you don't really know how to
solve it in an efficient way,
so you are going to split it up
into subproblems.
That is the divide.
You are going to divide that
problem, or more precisely the
instance of that problem,
the particular instance of that
problem you have into
subproblems.
And those subproblems should be
smaller in some sense.
And smaller means normally that
the value of N is smaller than
it was in the original problem.
So, you sort of made some
progress.
Now you have one,
or more likely you have several
subproblems you need to solve.
Each of them is smaller.
So, you recursively solve each
subproblem.
That is the conquer step.
You conquer each subproblem
recursively.
And then somehow you combine
those solutions into a solution
for the whole problem.
So, this is the general
divide-and-conquer paradigm.
And lots of algorithms fit it.
You have already seen one
algorithm that fits this
paradigm, if you can remember.
Merge sort, good.
Wow, you are all awake.
I'm impressed.
So, we saw merge sort.
And, if I am clever,
I could fit it in this space.
Sure.
Let's be clever.
A quick review on merge sort.
Phrased in this 1,
2, 3 kind of method.
The first step was to divide
your array into two halves.
This really doesn't mean
anything because you just sort
of think, oh,
I will pretend my array is
divided into two halves.
There is no work here.
This is zero time.
You just look at your array.
Here is your array.
I guess maybe you compute n/2
and take the floor.
That takes constant time.
And you say OK,
I am pretending my array is now
divided into the left part and
the right part.
And then the interesting part
is that you recursively solve
each one.
That's the conquer.
We recursively sort each
subarray.
And then the third step is to
combine those solutions.
And so here we really see what
this means.
We now have a sorted version of
this array by induction.
We have a sorted version of
We now want the sorted version
of the whole array.
And we saw that was the merge
problem, merging two sorted
arrays.
And that we saw how to do in
linear time, order n time.
I am not going to repeat that,
but the point is it falls into
that framework.
I want to write the running
time and merge sort as a
recurrence.
You have already seen the
recurrence, you have already
been told the solution,
but now we actually know how to
solve it.
And, furthermore,
every algorithm that follows
the divide-and-conquer paradigm
will have a recurrence of pretty
much the same form,
very much like our good friend
the master method.
Let's do it for merge sort
where we sort of already know
the answer and get a bit of
practice.
This is the merge sort
recurrence.
You should know and love this
recurrence because it comes up
all over the place.
It comes from this general
approach by just seeing what are
the sizes of the subproblems you
are solving and how many there
are and how much extra work you
are doing.
You have here the size of the
subproblems.
It happens here that both
subproblems have the same size
roughly.
There is this sloppiness that
we have, which really should be
T of floor of n over 2 plus T of
ceiling of n over 2.
And when you go to recitation
on Friday you will see why that
is OK, the floors and ceilings
don't matter.
There is a theorem you can
prove that that's happy.
You can assume that N is a
power of 2, but we are just
going to assume that for now.
We just have two problems with
size n over 2.
This 2 is the number of
subproblems.
And this order n is all the
extra work we are doing.
Now, what is the extra work
potentially?
Well, the conquering is always
just recursion.
There is sort of no work there
except this lead part.
The dividing in this case is
trivial, but in general it might
involve some work.
And the combining here involves
linear work.
So, this is the
divide-and-conquer running
times.
So, this is the nonrecursive
work.
And that is generally how you
convert a divide-and-conquer
algorithm into a recurrence.
It's really easy and you
usually get to apply the master
method.
Here we are in Case 2.
Very good.
This is Case 2.
And k is zero here.
And so in the recursion tree,
all of the costs are roughly
the same.
They are all n to the log base
b of a.
Here n to the log base 2 of 2
is just n.
So these are equal.
We get an extra log factor
because of the number of levels
in the recursion tree.
Remember the intuition behind
the master method.
This is n log n,
and that is good.
Merge sort is a fast sorting
algorithm n log n.
Insertion sort was n squared.
In some sense,
n log n is the best you can do.
We will cover that in two
lectures from now,
but just foreshadowing.
Today we are going to do
different divide-and-conquer
algorithms.
Sorting is one problem.
There are all sorts of problems
we might want to solve.
It turns out a lot of them you
can apply divide-and-conquer to.
Not every problem.
Like how to wake up in the
morning, it's not so easy to
solve a divide-and-conquer,
although maybe that's a good
problem set problem.
The next divide-and-conquer
algorithm we are going to look
at is even simpler than sorting,
even simpler than merge sort,
but it drives home the point of
when you have only one
subproblem.
How many people have seen
binary search before?
Anyone hasn't?
One, OK.
I will go very quickly then.
You have some element X.
You want to find X in a sorted
array.
How many people had not seen it
before they saw it in
recitation?
No one, OK.
Good.
You have seen it in another
class, probably 6.001 or
something.
Very good.
You took the prerequisites.
OK.
I just want to phrase it as a
divide-and-conquer because you
don't normally see it that way.
The divide step is you compare
X with the middle element in
your array.
Then the conquer step.
Here is your array.
Here is the middle element.
You compare X with this thing
if let's say X is smaller than
the middle element in your
array.
You know that X is in the left
half because it is sorted,
a nice loop invariant there,
whatever, but we are just going
to think of that as recursively
I am going to solve the problem
of finding X in this subarray.
We recurse in one subarray,
unlike merge sort where we had
two recursions.
And then the combined step we
don't do anything.
I mean if you find X in here
then you've found X in the whole
array.
There is nothing to bring it
back up really.
So, this is just phrasing
binary search in the
divide-and-conquer paradigm.
It is kind of a trivial
example, but there are lots of
circumstances where you only
need to recurse in one side.
And it is important to see how
much of a difference making one
recursion versus making two
recursions can be.
This is the recurrence for
binary search.
We start with a problem size n.
We reduce it to 1.
There is an implicit 1 factor
here.
One subproblem of size n over 2
roughly.
Again, floors and ceilings
don't matter.
Plus a constant which is to
compare X with the middle
element, so it is actually like
one comparison.
This has a solution,
log n.
And you all know the running
time of binary search,
but here it is at solving the
recurrence.
I mean, there are a couple of
differences here.
We don't have the additive
order n term.
If we did, it would be linear,
the running the time.
Still better than n log n.
So, we are getting rid of the
2, bringing it down to a 1,
taking the n and bringing it
down to a 1.
That is making the running time
a lot faster,
the whole factor of n faster.
No big surprise there.
Let's do some more interesting
algorithms.
The powering a number problem
is I give you a number X.
I give that as like a real
number or floating point number
or whatever.
And I give you an integer n,
at least zero.
I want to compute X to the
power n.
So, it's a very simple problem.
It is, in some sense,
even easier than all of these.
But here it is.
And divide-and-conquer is sort
of the right thing to do.
So, the naÔve algorithm is very
simple.
How do you compute X to the
power n?
Well, the definition of X to
the power n is I take X and I
multiply by X n times.
So, I take X times X times X
times X where there are n copies
of X totally.
And that's X to the n.
No big surprise.
That is n multiplications,
or n minus 1 multiplications,
theta n time.
But that's not the best you can
do for this problem.
Any suggestions on what we
might do using
divide-and-conquer?
Has anyone seen this algorithm
before?
A few, OK.
For the rest?
Testing on the spot creativity,
which is very difficult,
but I always like a challenge.
I mean random ideas.
What could we possibly do to
solve this problem in less than
linear time?
How is this sort of a
divide-and-conquer problem?
We have to inputs,
X and n.
Yeah?
We could try to divide on X.
It seems a bit hard.
It is just some number.
Or, we could try to divide on
n.
Any guesses?
Look at X to the n over 2,
very good.
That is exactly the idea of the
divide-and-conquer algorithm.
We would like to look at X to
the n over 2.
This is going to be a little
bit tricky.
Now we are going to have to pay
attention to floors and
ceilings.
What I would like to say is
while X to the n is X to the n
over 2 times X to the n over 2.
And this is true if n is even.
If it is odd then I need to be
a little bit more careful.
But let's just think about the
intuition why this is a good
divide-and-conquer algorithm.
We have a problem of size n,
let's say.
We convert it into,
it looks like two subproblems
of size n over 2,
but in fact they are the same
subproblems.
So, I only have to solve one of
them.
If I compute X to the n over 2.
Yeah, I know X to the n over 2.
So, there is one conversive
call, problem of size n over 2,
then I square that number.
And that is one computation.
So, exactly the same recurrence
as binary search,
log n time much better than n.
Cool.
I also have to solve the odd
case.
So, n is odd.
00:16:53,000 --> 00:00:02,000
I will look at n minus 1 over
N minus 1 better be even.
And then I am missing another
factor of X.
If n is odd,
I am going to have to do one
recursive call and two
multiplications.
The same recurrence.
One recursive problem of size n
over 2, plus constant time.
The dividing work here is
dividing by 2 and the
combination work is doing one or
possibly two multiplications.
And this is lg n.
And if all you are allowed to
do is multiply numbers,
lg n is the best you can do.
Good.
Simple but powerful.
Whenever you want to compute a
power of a number,
now you know what to do.
Does anyone not know the
definition of Fibonacci numbers
and is willing to admit it?
OK, so this is a good old
friend.
I will write down the
definition as just a reminder.
And, in particular,
the base cases.
Fibonacci numbers,
I will claim,
are very important because it
appears throughout nature.
You look at certain fruits,
you see the Fibonacci sequence.
If you count the number of
little bumps around each ring.
If you look at the sand on the
beach and how the waves hit it,
it's the Fibonacci sequence I
am told.
If you look all over the place,
Fibonacci sequence is there.
How does nature compute the
Fibonacci sequence?
Well, that is a different
class.
But how are we going to compute
the Fibonacci sequence as fast
as possible?
You have probably seen two
algorithms.
The most naÔve algorithm is the
recursive algorithm.
Where you say OK,
f of n.
I say well, if n is zero,
return zero,
if n is 1, return one.
Otherwise, recursively compute
f of n minus 1 and f of n minus
2, add them together.
How much time does this
algorithm take,
for those who have seen it
before?
This is not obvious to guess.
It doesn't have to be exact.
OK.
And how many people have seen
this algorithm before and
analyzed it?
Half, OK.
So what is the running time?
Really, really long,
very good.
Anymore precise answers?
What's that?
Exponential,
yes.
That is also correct and more
precise.
I will be even more precise.
Maybe you haven't seen this
analysis before.
It's phi to the n where phi is
the Golden Ratio.
Again, Golden Ratio appears
throughout the world in
mathematics.
This is probably the only time
in this class,
I'm afraid, but there we go.
It made its cameo so we are
happy.
This is called exponential
time.
This is bigger than one,
that's all you need to know.
This is exponential time.
Exponential time means
basically some constant to the
power n.
Exponential time is a very long
time.
It's bad.
Polynomial time is good.
[LAUGHTER] This is what we
want, polynomial time
algorithms.
This class is basically
entirely about polynomial time
algorithms.
Question?
Oh, say what the algorithm does
again.
Define function Fibonacci of n?
I check for the base cases.
Otherwise, I recursively call
Fibonacci of n minus 1.
I recursively call Fibonacci of
n minus 2 and add those two
numbers together.
So, you get this branching
tree.
You are solving two subproblems
of almost the same size,
just additively smaller by one
or two.
I mean you are almost not
reducing the problem size at
all, so that's intuitively why
it is exponential.
You can draw a recursion tree
and you will see how big it gets
and how quickly.
I mean by n over two levels,
you've only reduced on one
branch the problem from n to n
over 2.
The other one,
maybe you've gotten from n down
to one, but none of the branches
have stopped after n of two
levels.
You have at least 2 to the
power n over 2 which is like
square root of 2 to the power n,
which is getting close to phi
to the n.
So, this is definitely
exponential.
And exponential is bad.
We want polynomial.
N squared, n cubed,
log n would be nice.
Anything that is bounded above
by a polynomial is good.
This is an old idea.
It goes back to one of the main
people who said polynomial is
good, Jack Edmonds who is famous
in the combinatorial
optimization world.
He is my academic grandfather
on one side.
He is a very interesting guy.
OK, so that's a really bad
algorithm.
You have probably seen a
somewhat better algorithm,
which you might think of as the
bottom-up implantation of that
recursive algorithm.
Or, another way to think of it
is if you build out the
recursion tree for Fibonacci of
n, you will see that there are
lots of common subtrees that you
are just wasting time on.
When you solve Fibonacci of n
minus 1, it again solves
Fibonacci of n minus 2.
Why solve it twice?
You only need to solve it once.
So, it is really easy to do
that if you do it bottom-up.
But you could also do it
recursively with some cache of
things you have already
computed.
So, no big surprise.
You compute the Fibonacci
numbers in order.
And each time,
when you compute Fibonacci of
n, let's say,
you have already computed the
previous two,
you add them together,
it takes constant time.
So, the running time here is
linear, linear in n,
and as our input.
Great.
Is that the best we can do?
No.
Any ideas on how we could
compute Fibonacci of n faster
than linear time?
Now we should diverge from what
you have already seen,
most of you.
Any ideas using techniques you
have already seen?
Yes?
Yes.
We can use the mathematical
trick of phi and psi to the nth
powers.
In fact, you can just use phi,
phi, pi, pho,
phum, whatever you want to call
this Greek letter.
Good.
Here is the mathematical trick.
And, indeed,
this is cheating,
as you have said.
This is no good,
but so it is.
We will call it naÔve recursive
squaring and say well,
we know recursive squaring.
Recursive squaring takes log n
time.
Let's use recursive squaring.
And if you happen to know lots
of properties of the Fibonacci
numbers, you don't have to,
but here is one of them.
If you take phi to the n
divided by root 5 and you round
it to the nearest integer that
is the nth Fibonacci number.
This is pretty cool.
Fibonacci of n is basically phi
to the n.
We could apply recursive
squaring to compute phi to the n
in log n time,
divide by root 5,
assume that our computer has an
operation that rounds a number
to its nearest integer and poof,
we are done.
That doesn't work for many
different reasons.
On a real machine,
probably you would represent
phi and root 5 as floating point
numbers which have some fixed
amount of precise bits.
And if you do this computation,
you will lose some of the
important bits.
And when you round to the
nearest integer you won't get
the right answer.
So, floating point round off
will kill you on a floating
point machine.
On a theoretical machine where
we magically have numbers that
can do crazy things like this,
I mean it really takes more
than constant time per
multiplication.
So, we are sort of in a
different model.
You cannot multiply phi times
phi in constant time.
I mean that's sort of outside
the boundaries of this course,
but that's the way it is.
In fact, in a normal machine,
some problems you can only
solve in exponential time.
In a machine where you can
multiply real numbers and round
them to the nearest integers,
you can solve them in
polynomial time.
So, it really breaks the model.
You can do crazy things if you
were allowed to do this.
This is not allowed.
And I am foreshadowing like
three classes ahead,
or three courses ahead,
so I shouldn't talk more about
it.
But it turns out we can use
recursive squaring in a
different way if we use a
different property of Fibonacci
numbers.
And then we will just stick
with integers and everything
will be happy.
Don't forget to go to
recitation and if you want to
homework lab.
Don't come here on Monday.
That is required.
This is sort of the right
recursive squaring algorithm.
And this is a bit hard to guess
if you haven't already seen it,
so I will just give it to you.
I will call this a theorem.
It's the first time I get to
use the word theorem in this
class.
It turns out the nth Fibonacci
number is the nth power of this
matrix.
Cool.
If you look at it a little bit
you say oh, yeah,
of course.
And we will prove this theorem
in a second.
But once we have this theorem,
we can compute f of n by
computing the nth power of this
matrix.
It's a two-by-two matrix.
You multiply two two-by-two
matrixes together,
you get a two-by-two matrix.
So that is constant size,
four numbers.
I can handle four numbers.
We don't have crazy precision
problems on the floating point
side.
There are only four numbers to
deal with.
Matrixes aren't getting bigger.
So, the running time of this
divide-and-conquer algorithm
will still be log n because it
takes a constant time per
two-by-two matrix
multiplication.
Yes?
Oh, yes.
Thank you.
I have a type error.
Sorry about that.
F of n is indeed the upper left
corner, I hope.
I better check I don't have it
off by one.
I do.
It's F_n upper right corner,
indeed.
That's what you said.
F of n.
I need more space.
Sorry.
I really ought to have a
two-by-two matrix on the
left-hand side there.
Thank you.
So, I compute this nth power of
a matrix in log n time,
I take the upper right corner
or the lower left corner,
your choice,
that is the nth Fibonacci
number.
This implies an order log n
time algorithm with the same
recurrence as the last two,
binary search and really the
recursive squaring algorithm.
It is log n plus a constant,
so log n.
Let's prove that theorem.
Any suggestions on what
techniques we might use for
proving this theorem,
or what technique,
singular?
Induction, very good.
I think any time I ask that
question the answer is
induction.
Hint for the future in this
class.
A friend of mine,
when he took an analysis class,
whenever the professor asked,
and what is the answer to this
question, the answer was always
zero.
If you have taken analysis
class that is funny.
[LAUGHTER] Maybe I will try to
ask some questions whose answers
are zero just for our own
amusement.
We are going to induct on n.
It's pretty much the obvious
thing to do.
But we have to check some
cases.
So, the base case is we have
this to the first power.
And that is itself [(1,
1), (1, 0)].
And I should have said n is at
least 1.
And you can check.
This is supposed to be F_2,
F_1, F_1, F_0.
And you can check it is,
F_0 is 0, F_1 is 1 and F_2 is
00:30:46,000 --> 00:00:01,000
Base case is correct,
step case is about as exciting,
Good.
but you've got to prove that
your algorithm works.
Suppose this is what we want to
compute.
I am just going to sort of,
well, there are many ways I can
do this.
I will just do it the fast way
because it's really not that
exciting.
Which direction?
Let's do this direction.
I want to use induction on n.
If I want to use induction on
n, presumably I should use what
I already know is true.
If I decrease n by 1,
I have this property that this
thing is going to be [(1,
1), (1, 0)] to the power n
minus 1.
This I already know,
by the induction hypothesis,
[(1, 1), (1,
0)] to the n minus 1.
So, presumably I should use it
in some way.
This equality is not yet true,
you may have noticed.
So, I need to add something on.
What could I possibly add on to
be correct?
Well, another factor of [(1,
1), (1, 0)].
The way I am developing this
proof is the only way it could
possibly be, in some sense.
If you know its induction,
this is all that you could do.
And then you check.
Indeed, this equality holds
conveniently.
For example,
F_(n plus 1) is the product of
these two things.
It is this row times this
column.
So, it is F_n times 1 plus F_(n
minus 1) times 1,
which is indeed the definition
of F_(n plus 1).
And you could check four of the
entries.
This is true.
Great.
If that is true then I would
just put these together.
That is [(1,
1), (1, 0)] to the n minus 1
times [(1, 1),
(1, 0)], which is [(1,
1), (1, 0)] to the n,
end of proof.
A very simple proof,
but you have to do that in
order to know if this algorithm
really works.
Good.
Question?
Oh, yes.
Thank you.
This, in the lower right,
we should have F_(n minus 1).
This is why you should really
check your proofs.
We would have discovered that
when I checked that this was
that row times that column,
but that is why you are here,
to fix my bugs.
That's the great thing about
being up here instead of in a
quiz.
But that is a minor mistake.
You wouldn't lose much for
that.
All right.
More divide-and-conquer
algorithms.
Still, we have done relatively
simple ones so far.
In fact, the fanciest has been
merge sort, which we already
saw.
So, that is not too exciting.
The rest have all be log n
time.
Let's break out of the log n
world.
Well, you all have the master
method memorized,
right, so I can erase that.
Good.
This will be a good test.
Next problem is matrix
multiplication,
following right up on this
two-by-two matrix
multiplication.
Let's see how we can compute
n-by-n matrix multiplications.
Just for a recap,
you should know how to multiply
matrixes, but here is the
definition so we can turn it
into an algorithm.
You have two matrixes,
A and B, which are capital
levels.
The ijth entry.
Ith row, jth column is called
little a_ij or little b_ij.
And your goal is to compute the
products of those matrixes.
I should probably say that i
and j range from 1 to n.
So, they are square matrixes.
The output is to compute C
which has entry c_ij which is
the product of A and B.
And, for a recap,
the ijth entry of the product
is the inner product of the ith
row of A with the jth column of
B.
But you can write that out as a
sum like so.
We want to compute this thing
for every i and j.
What is the obvious algorithm
for doing this?
Well, for every i and j you
compute the sum.
You compute all the products.
You compute the sum.
So, it's like n operations here
roughly.
I mean like 2n minus 1,
whatever.
It is order n operations.
There are n^2 entries of C that
I need to compute,
so that's n^3 time.
I will write this out just for
the programmers at heart.
Here is the pseudocode.
It's rare that I will write
pseudocode.
And this is a simple enough
algorithm that I can write it in
gory detail.
But it gives you some basis for
this analysis if you like to
program.
It is a triply nested for loop.
And I made a coding error.
Hopefully you haven't written
that far yet.
I need c_ij to be initialized
to zero.
And then I add to c_ij the
appropriate product,
a_ik, b_kj.
That is the algorithm.
And the point is you have a
nesting of n for loops from 1 to
n.
That takes n^3 time because
this is constant and that is
constant.
So, very simple,
n^3.
Let's do better.
And, of course,
we are going to use
divide-and-conquer.
Now, how are we going to divide
a matrix?
There are a lot of numbers in a
matrix, n^2 of them in each one.
There are all sorts of ways you
could divide.
So far all of the
divide-and-conquers we have done
have been problems of size n
into some number of problems of
size n over 2.
I am going to say I start with
some matrixes of size n-by-n.
I want to convert it down to
something like n/2-by-n/2.
Any suggestions how I might do
that?
Yeah?
Block form the matrix,
indeed.
That is the right answer.
So, this is the first
divide-and-conquer algorithm.
This will not work,
but it has the first idea that
we need.
We have a n-by-n matrix.
We can view it,
this equality is more,
you can think of it as,
it's really the thing,
a two-by-two block matrix where
each entry in this two-by-two
block matrix is a block of
n/2-by-n/2 submatrixes.
I will think of C as being
divided into three parts,
r, s, t and u.
Even though I write them as
lower case letters they are
really matrixes.
Each is n/2-by-n/2.
And A, I will split into a,
b, c, d, times B,
I will split into e,
f, g, h.
Why not?
This is certainly true.
And if you've seen some linear
algebra, this is basically what
you can do with matrixes.
Now I can pretend these are
two-by-two and sort of forget
the fact that these little
letters are matrixes and say
well, r is the inner product of
this row with this column.
It is ae times bg.
Let me not cheat or else it
will be too easy.
r=ae+bg, s=af+bh,
t=ce+dh and u=cf+dg.
It's nothing like making it too
hard on yourself.
OK, got them right.
Good.
I mean this is just a fact
about how you would expand out
this product.
And so now we have a recursive
algorithm.
In fact, we have a
divide-and-conquer algorithm.
We start with our n-by-n
matrix.
Well, we have two of them
actually.
We divide it into eight little
pieces, a, b,
c, d, e, f, g,
h.
Then we compute these things
and that gives us C,
just by sticking them together.
Now, how do we compute these
things?
Well, these innocent-looking
little products between these
two little numbers are actually
recursive matrix
multiplications.
Because each of these little
letters is an n/2-by-n/2 matrix
so I have to recursively compute
the product.
There are like eight recursive
multiplications of n/2-by-n/2
matrixes.
That is what bites us.
And then there are like four
additions, plus minor work of
gluing things together.
How long does it take to add
two matrixes together?
n^2.
This is cheap.
It just takes n^2.
Remember, we are trying to beat
n^3 for our matrix
multiplication.
Addition is a really easy
problem.
You just have to add every
number.
There is no way you can do
better than n^2.
So, that is not recursive.
That is the nice thing.
But the bad thing is we have
eight of these recursions.
We have
T(n)=8T(n/2)+Theta(n^2).
And I have erased the master
method, but you should all have
it memorized.
What is the solution to this
recurrence?
Theta(n^3).
That is annoying.
All right.
A is 8, b is 2,
log base 2 of 8 is 3.
Every computer scientist should
know that.
n^log_b(a)=n^3.
That is polynomially larger
than n^2, so we are in Case 1.
Thank you.
Let's get them upside down.
This is n^3,
no better than our previous
algorithm.
That kind of sucks.
And now comes the divine
inspiration.
Let's go over here.
There are some algorithms like
this Fibonacci algorithm where
if you sat down for a little
while, it's no big deal,
you would figure it out.
I mean it is kind of clever to
look at that matrix and then
everything works happily.
It is not obvious but it is not
that amazingly clever.
This is an algorithm that is
amazingly clever.
You may have seen it before
which steals the thunder a
little bit, but it is still
really, really cool so you
should be happy to see it again.
And how Strassen came up with
this algorithm,
he must have been very clever.
The idea is we've got to get
rid of these multiplications.
I could do a hundred additions.
That only costs Theta(n^2).
I have to reduce this 8 to
something smaller.
It turns out,
if you try to split the
matrices into three-by-three or
something, that doesn't help
you.
You get the same problem
because we're using
fundamentally the same
algorithm, just in a different
order.
We have got to somehow reduce
the number of multiplications.
We are going to reduce it to 7.
The claim is that if we have
two two-by-two matrices we can
take their product using seven
multiplications.
If that were true,
we would reduce the 8 to a 7
and presumably make things run
faster.
We will see how fast in a
moment.
You can compute it in your
head.
If you are bored and like
computing logs that are
non-integral logs then go ahead.
All right.
Here we are.
This algorithm is unfortunately
rather long, but it is only
seven multiplications.
Each of these P's is a product
of two things which only
involves addition or
subtraction, the same thing.
Those are seven
multiplications.
And I can compute those in
7T(n/2).
Oh, indeed it is.
Six was wrong.
Six and seven are the same,
very good.
You know, you think that
copying something would not be
such a challenging task.
But when you become an
absent-minded professor like me
then you will know how easy it
is.
OK.
We have them all correct,
hopefully.
We continue.
That wasn't enough.
Of course we had seven things.
Clearly we have to reduce this
down to four things,
the elements of C.
Here they are,
the elements of C,
r, s, t, u.
It turns out r=P_5+P_4-P_2+P_6.
Of course.
Didn't you all see that?
[LAUGHTER]
I mean this one is really easy,
s=P_1+P2.
t=P_3+P_4.
I mean that is clearly how they
were chosen.
And then u is another tricky
one, u=P_5+P_1-P_3-P_7.
OK.
Now, which one of these would
you like me to check?
Don't be so nice.
How about s?
I can show you s is right.
Any preferences?
u.
Oh, no, sign errors.
OK.
Here we go.
The claim that this really
works is you have to check all
four of them.
And I did in my notes.
u=P_5.
P_5=(ae + ah + de + dh).
That is P_5.
Check me.
If I screw up,
I am really hosed.
(af - ah) = P_1.
P_3 has a minus sign in front,
so that is (ce + de).
And then we have minus P_7,
which is a big one,
(ae + af - ce - cf).
OK.
Now I need like the assistant
that crosses off things in
parallel like the movie,
right?
ah, de, af, ce,
ae, thank you,
and hopefully these survive,
dh minus minus cf.
And, if we are lucky,
that is exactly what is written
here, except in the opposite
order.
Magic, right?
Where the hell did Strassen get
this?
You have to be careful.
It is OK that the plus is in
the wrong order because plus is
commutative, but the
multiplications better not be in
the wrong order because
multiplication over matrixes is
not commutative.
I check cf, OK,
dh, they are in the right
order.
I won't check the other three.
That is matrix multiplication
in hopefully subcubic time.
Let's write down the
recurrence.
T(n) is now 7.
Maybe I should write down the
algorithm for kicks.
Why not?
Assuming I have time.
Lots of time.
Last lecture I was ten minutes
early.
I ended ten minutes early.
I apologize for that.
I know it really upsets you.
And I didn't realize exactly
when the class was supposed to
end.
So, today, I get to go ten
minutes late.
OK.
Good.
I'm glad you all agree.
[LAUGHTER] I am kidding.
Don't worry.
OK.
Algorithm.
This is Strassen.
First we divide,
then we conquer and then we
combine.
As usual, I don't have it
written anywhere here.
Fine.
Divide A and B.
This is sort of trivial.
Then we compute the terms --
-- for the products.
This means we get ready to
compute all the P's.
We compute a+b,
c+d, g-e, a+d,
e+h and so on.
All of the terms that appear in
here, we compute those.
That takes n2 time because it
is just a bunch of additions and
subtractions.
No big deal.
A constant number of them.
Then we conquer by recursively
computing all the P_i's.
That is each our product of
seven of them.
We have P_1,
P_2 up to P_7.
And, finally,
we combine, which is to compute
r, s, t and u.
And those are just additions
and subtractions again,
so they take n^2 times.
So, here we finally get an
algorithm that is nontrivial
both in dividing and in
combining.
Recursion is always recursion,
but now we have interesting
steps one and three.
The recurrence is T(n) is seven
recursive subproblems,
each are size n/2 plus order
n^2, to do all this addition
work.
Now we need to solve this
recurrence.
We compute n^log_b(a),
which here is nlog_2(7).
And we know log base 2 of 8 is
00:52:16,000 --> 00:00:03,000
Log base 2 of 7 is going be a
little bit less than 3 but still
bigger than 2 because log base 2
of 4 is 2.
So, it is going to be
polynomially larger than n^2 but
polynomially smaller than n^3.
We are again in Case 1.
And this is the cheating way to
write n log base 2 of 7,
nlg7.
lg means log base 2.
You should know that.
It is all over the textbook and
in our problem sets and what
not, nlg7.
And, in particular,
if I have my calculator here.
This is a good old-fashion
calculator.
No, that is wrong.
Sorry.
It is strictly less than 2.81.
That is cool.
I mean it is polynomially
better than n^3.
Still not as good as addition,
which is n^2.
It is generally believed,
although we don't know whether
you can multiply as fast as you
can divide for matrices.
We think you cannot get n^2,
but who knows?
It could still happen.
There are no lower bounds.
This is not the best algorithm
for matrix multiplication.
It is sort of the simplest that
beats n^3.
The best so far is like
n^2.376.
Getting closer to 2.
You might think these numbers
are a bit weird.
Maybe the constants out here
dominate the improvement you are
getting in the exponent.
It turns out improving the
exponent is a big deal.
I mean, as n gets larger
exponents really come out to
bite you.
So, n^3 is pretty impractical
for any very large values of n.
And we known that Strassen will
beat normal matrix
multiplication if n is
sufficiently large.
The claim is that roughly at
about 32 or so already you get
an improvement,
for other reasons,
not just because the exponent
gets better, but there you go.
So, this is pretty good.
This is completely impractical,
so don't use whatever this
algorithm is.
I don't have the reference
handy, but it is just trying to
get a theoretical improvement.
There may be others that are in
between and more reasonable but
that is not it.
Wow, lots of time.
Any questions?
We're not done yet,
but any questions before we
move on for matrix
multiplication?
OK.
I have one more problem.
Divide-and-conquer is a pretty
general idea.
I mean, you can use it to
dominate countries.
You can use it to multiply
matrices.
I mean, who would have thought?
Here is a very different kind
of problem you can solve with
divide-and-conquer.
It is not exactly an
algorithmic problem,
although it is computer
science.
That is clear.
This is very large-scale
integration.
The chips, they are very large
scale integrated.
Probably even more these days,
but that is the catch phrase.
Here is a problem,
and it arises in VLSI layout.
We won't get into too many
details why, but you have some
circuit.
And here I am going to assume
that the circuit is a binary
tree.
This is just part of a circuit.
Assume for now here that it is
just a complete binary tree.
A complete binary tree looks
like this.
In all of my teachings,
I have drawn this figure for
sure the most.
It is my favorite figure,
the height four complete binary
tree.
OK, there it is.
I have some tree like that as
some height.
I want to imbed it into some
chip layout on a grid.
Let's say it has n leaves.
I want to imbed it into a grid
with minimum area.
This is a very cute problem and
it really shows you another way
in which divide-and-conquer is a
useful and powerful tool.
So, I have this tree.
I like to draw it in this way.
I want to somehow draw it on
the grid.
What that means is the vertices
have to be imbedded onto dots on
the grid, and I am talking about
the square grid.
It has to go to vertices of the
grid.
And these edges have to be
routed as sort of orthogonal
paths between one dot and
another, so that should be an
edge and they shouldn't cross
and all these good things
because wires do not like to
cross.
There is the obvious way to
solve this problem and there is
the right way.
And let's talk about both of
them.
Neither of them is particularly
obvious, but divide-and-conquer
sort of gives you a hint in the
right direction.
So, the naÔve imbedding.
I seem to like the word naÔve
here.
I am going to draw this bottom
up because it is easier,
so leave three grid lines and
then start drawing.
I don't know how big that is
going to be.
Here is the bottom of our tree.
This is like the little three
nodes there.
And then I leave a blank column
and then a blank column.
I don't actually need to leave
those blank columns,
but it makes a prettier
drawing.
And then we work our way up.
There is the tree,
which should be aligned,
on a grid.
No crossings.
Everything is happy.
How much area does it take?
By area, I mean sort of the
area of the bounding box.
So, I count this blank space
even though I am not using it
and I count all this blank space
even though I am not using it.
I want to look at the height.
Let's call this H(n).
And to look at the width,
which I will call W(n).
Now, it is probably pretty
obvious that H(n) is like log n,
W(n) is like n or whatever.
But I want to write it as a
recurrence because that will
inspire us to do the right
thing.
H(n).
Well, if you think of this as a
recursion-tree,
in some sense.
We start with the big tree.
We split it into two halves,
two subtrees of size n/2 indeed
because we are counting leaves.
It is exactly n/2 on each side.
Then for height they are in
parallel so it is no big deal.
The height is just the height
of this thing,
one of these subproblems plus
one.
The width, you have to add
together the two widths and also
add on 1.
You don't have to add on 1
here, but it doesn't matter.
It is certainly at most 1.
H(n) = H(n/2) + Theta(1),
there you do have to add 1,
and W(n) = 2W(n/2) + O(1).
The usual base cases.
I mean, these are recurrences
we should know and love.
This is log n,
I sort of have already given
away the answers,
and this better be linear.
This is again Case 1.
And to the log base 2 of 2 is
n, which is the answer,
much bigger than 1.
And here n to the log base 2 of
1 is n to the zero,
which is 1, which is the same
so we get log n.
The area is n log n,
but if you are making chips you
want the area as small as
possible so you can fit more
good stuff in there.
So, we would like to aim for,
well, we certainly cannot do a
better area than n.
You've got to put the leaves
down somewhere,
but this is already pretty
good.
It is only a log factor off,
but we want to aim for n.
How could we get n?
Any guesses on what needs to
change in this layout?
Not how to do it because that
is not obvious,
but in terms of height and
width what should we do?
It is pretty hard to get the
height smaller than log n,
I will tell you,
because this is a tree.
It cannot really get its width
down to less than log n.
What could we do to make the
product linear?
Just random ideas.
What are two functions whose
product is n?
Square root of n and square
root of n.
That is a good choice.
Were there other suggestions?
n times constant.
Yeah, n times constant would be
nice.
But I claim you cannot get
either of these down to less
than a constant.
You could aim for n over log n
by log n, that is more likely,
but I think that is almost
impossible.
Root n by root n is the right
answer, so let's go with that.
So, root n by root n.
We haven't seen any recurrences
whose solution is root n,
but surely they are out there.
Let's say the goal is to get
W(n) = Theta(root n) and to get
H(n) = Theta(root n).
If we did that we would be
happy, because then the area is
the product is linear.
How?
What is a recurrence that is in
the usual master method form
whose solution is root n?
I mean, you could think of it
that way.
Recurrence is a bit tricky,
but let's just think of
n^log_b(a).
When is log base b of a Ω?
Because then n^log_b(a) is root
n.
And there is some hope that I
could get a root n solution to
recurrence.
This is designed by knowing
that it is divide-and-conquer,
and therefore it must be
something like this.
It is easy once you know the
approach you are supposed to
take and you can try this
approach.
When is log base b of a Ω?
Lots of solutions,
shout them out.
4 and 2, that is a good one.
I better get this right.
Log base 4 of 2 is Ω because
the square root of 4 is 2.
So, let's aim for this.
Why not?
When would we get log base 4 of
2?
This is b, this is a,
so it should be 2T(n/4) plus
something.
And if I want the n^log_b(a) to
dominate, it has got to be
polynomially smaller than root
n.
So, this should be
n^1/2-epsilon.
But it could be smaller.
It could be 1.
Zero would be nice,
but that is probably too much
to hope for.
So, something smaller,
strictly polynomially smaller
than root n.
That is our goal.
And now comes the magic.
If you played with this for a
while you would find it,
I think, at this point.
When you know that you are
somehow solve this problem of
size n with two subproblems of
size n/4 what could you do?
Well, if you start thinking of
things as squares,
this is the natural thing that
happens.
This is called the H layout.
You can imagine why.
It would be much easier to draw
if I had a grid board,
a graph board,
whatever, if that exists.
This is a recursive layout.
I am only going to draw a
couple iterations,
but hopefully you can imagine
the generalization.
I take four Hs,
a good plan because I want
problems of size n/4.
This has n/4 leaves.
This is the root,
by the way, in the middle.
This has n/4 leaves.
So, I have four problems of
size n/4.
Somehow I have got to get that
down to two.
Thankfully, if I look at width
or if I look at height,
there are only two that matter.
And these two matter and these
two get along for free.
They are going in parallel,
just like we had with height
over here.
But I get that both in height
and in width.
If I measure,
well, now they are equal,
so I will just call them the
length.
We have L(n)-by-L(n).
And if I compute well,
what is L(n)?
I have here L(n/4) because
there are only a quarter of the
leaves in this one or in that
one, then I have a constant,
Theta(1), no big deal,
and then I have L(n/4) again.
So, I get the recurrence that I
wanted.
L(n) = 2L(n/4) + Theta(1).
And that has solution square
root of n, as we claimed before.
Again, we are in Case 1 of the
master method.
Cool, ha?
This is a much more compact
layout.
Charles, did you invent this
layout?
No.
But I know it appears on your
PhD thesis and you extended it
in various directions.
So, this is sort of a classic
cool layout of trees into grids
and another application of
divide-and-conquer.
I mean this is not particularly
useful for algorithms directly.
It is useful for VLSI layout
directly.
But it gives you more flavor of
how you should think.
If you know what running time
you are aiming for,
like in problem sets in quizzes
often we say here is the running
time you have got to get,
think about the recurrence that
will get you there.
And that could inspire you.
And that is it.
Recitation Friday.
Homework lab Sunday.
No class Monday.
See you Wednesday.